You have built the user interface and
imported the extension to
the PlaySoundsViewController.
We're in the final step to getting
pitch perfect to playback the audio.
Let me walk you through
what we need to set up.
If you think back to earlier
in this lesson, we wired up
all six sound effect buttons to call
the play sound for button function.
What we need now is a way to distinguish
between each of these buttons.
And then call the appropriate
function in our extension
to play that sound effect.
There are several ways to distinguish
one UI button from another.
But the easiest is using
the tag property of the button.
This is just an integer value
we can assign the UI button.
And then later query in the play
sound for button function.
With a button selected, in
the attributes inspector open, you can
scroll down to the view section and
see the tag here, on the bottom right.
The default tag value is 0.
Therefore, all of our UI buttons
have 0 as their tag value.
Time to change that.
The snail button is the first button.
So it can have a tag of 0, but we should
change it for the other five buttons.
Open the main.storyboard and
select the place sounds view
controller scene, as I've done here.
Select the rabbit button,
scroll down to the tag, and set it to 1.
Now select the chipmunk button and
in the attributes inspector,
set the tag to 2.
For the Darth Vader button,
set the tag to 3.
For the EchoButton, set the tag to 4.
Finally for the ReverbButton,
set the tag to 4.
Now we have different tag values for
each playback button from 0 to 5.
The next step is to change the play
sound for button function.
So it does a different audio playback
depending on what button was pressed.
Let's go to that function in
the PlaySoundsViewController.swift file.
To make more space, we can use
Cmd+Option+0 to close the right side.
Remember the enumeration you added
earlier here for values from 0 to 5?
We can use them in the switch
statement to call the playSound
function differently for
each of the buttons.
Add the code for the switch statements
that appears as you can see here.
If the slow or
fast button is pressed, we'll play
the sound at a different rate.
If the chipmunk or Darth Vader voices
are selected, we'll alter the pitch.
If echo or
reverb sound effects are selected,
we'll pass the settings onward
to the playSound function.
While playing audio was great,
it would be nice if we could
stop playback when we want to.
We do have a stop button and it's
already wired up to call the stop button
press function in our
playSoundsViewController.
All we need to do is to add
a call to the stop audio function
that is in the class extension.
And they'll do the work of calling out
every audio engine to stop the playback.
If you follow along to this point,
we should be able to test
the Pitch Perfect app.
You should be able to
record yourself and
hear the playback with
a variety of sound effects.
Let's try it.
Swift is great.
>> Swift is great.
>> In the very short amount of time,
you got pitch perfect
built from the ground up.
A fun iOS app that can record and
playback audio with sound effects.
If you're curious about
the calls to AV audio engine,
I'm going to go over that next.
For now, pat yourself on the back.
You are already an iOS developer